I have always looked for physics that
you can test and I mean in my lifetime
not 300 years from now so I work on dark
matter that you can test that is being
tested we were behind some of the tests
that are going on now and also on
inflation when we realize you can test
this not just the idea of inflation
overall but individual models are
testable because of the density of
perations because of these primordial B
modes that simonm Observatory is really
gunning for and that is frankly why I
got all excited about CNB experiments
because I thought we're going to get the
B modes we're going to prove that
natural inflation is right